[Musique]
en
france
un axe bois d'afrique
parce que je veux mourir oui
probablement
ça ne va pas
c'est j'ai pas quoi reste là bas des
gens restent là c'est maman qui m'a
donné ton corps tu sais maman
ce genre c'est maman qui m'a donné ton
coeur
bassin doit version artistes baisse un
droit s'était déjà oublié les paroles
d'un de tes it sur scène bassin toi si
tu stresses toujours avant de monter sur
scène baisse un doigt si on t'a déjà
confondue avec une autre star belle sein
droit si tu as déjà eu des paparazzi qui
ont suivi baisse un doigt si la première
personne que tu contacter le matin et
ton manager baisse un doigt si tu aime
avoir des mouvements dans sa loge bassin
d'oise tu t'es déjà fait draguer par une
autre star en dm baisse un doigt c'est
quand tu es en studio tu bois beaucoup
d'eau baisse un doigt si tu es heureux
heureuse de rencontrer des fans et
baisse un droit c'était réseau préféré
son tik tok et instinct
[Musique]
but what the doors
mais enfin
c'est un grand fan du québec pour être
si près n'importe quoi ça te dérange pas
non
[Musique]
présentement et franck dubosc 1/2 rumeur
est française j'ai tellement d'émotion
des mandats admiration devant ce
personnage vraiment autarcie l'a dit un
des meilleurs
et oncle oscar 10 23 je déteste les
devinettes je vais devenir roi de la
terre des lions
auquel choix mon père m'a montré royaume
et c'est moi qui couve aimerait tous
pardonne moi de ne pas trépigner de
bonheur problème de lumbagos
on commence car quand je fait roi toi tu
deviendras quoi bouffon du roi
ce que t'es bizarre
united et
[Musique]